some local spas in a popular massage
chain are facing allegations of sexual
assault but they have mishandled those
claims an investigation by BuzzFeed news
found more than 180 women have accused
therapists at Massage Envy of groping
and other sexual acts meg Oliver has the
story of one victim Meg good morning
good morning Massage Envy tells us
they're therapists have done 125 million
massages over the past 15 years still it
says even one incident is too many but
BuzzFeed reports there have been
multiple complaints which customers
claimed the company mishandled I was
really in a state of shock disbelief
fear Suzan Ingram says her masseur
turned into a sexual predator during her
seventh visit with him at this Massage
Envy location in 2015 she says it
started when James dieter began rubbing
his groin against her he lifted up my
body groped both of my breasts roughly
and aggressively put his hands down to
the lower part of my body to disturbed
to report the assault immediately she
called the manager after she got home
she said in a very parently scripted
response we invite you in to talk about
your services you don't understand
according to BuzzFeed news Ingram is
just one of more than 180 women who have
filed sexual assault lawsuits police
reports and state board complaints
against Massage Envy spa
their employees and the national company
over 100 reported that massage
therapists groped their genitals groped
their breasts or committed other
explicit violations BuzzFeed news
investigative reporter Katie Baker what
stood out to you the most in your
reporting I think that the descriptions
of the sexual assault claims that I
heard were really horrific but to me
it's awful to be assaulted when you're
in a very vulnerable position in it but
I think that for some women it's even
worse to go and report what happened to
you and not have it taken seriously
according to BuzzFeed Massage Envy only
requires franchises to conduct internal
investigations of abuse claims it
in the few states that required
notification of local law enforcement I
just found that these Massage Envy spa
employees we're not equipped to handle
serious allegations of sexual assualt
all on their own Massage Envy has more
than 1,100 locations serving more than
one and a half million members in a
statement it says we are constantly
listening learning and looking at how we
can do more including how we support
franchise locations with best practices
in handling these incidents and
supporting their clients it should be
something that they train for and and
have an understanding of how they're to
respond after Ingram filed a formal
police report dieter pleaded guilty to
sexually molesting a total of nine
female clients and is now behind bars
citing court records BuzzFeed says two
of those women had tried to warn the spa
about dieter before Ingram had Massage
Envy needs to stop it needs to protect
needs to apologize and to do the right
thing Ingram is suing Massage Envy and
taking other steps to make sure spa
companies do the right thing she helped
draft federal legislation that would
require massage spas to report sexual
assault allegations to police we reached
out to the franchise where Ingram says
she was assaulted but they declined to
comment and Katie said after her story
broke several more women have already
come forward that's normally how it goes
but it's so disturbing because it's not
just one Massage Envy store it's
different franchises around the country
right they're all independently owned
and what she found was that a lot of
these franchises didn't take the report
seriously because the women waited to
call over the phone they didn't do it in
person it's very disturbing thanks man
Thank You Meg